ah you again yeah I work here so that
shouldn't surprise you no I was just
being trying to be funny
trying being the key word those cases
come in yet so why are they so expensive
if they're banned don't act like you
didn't just look it up come on
trying to extend an olive branch help me
out the Black Lotus is too powerful it's
one of the power 9 oh yes I'm guessing
this one rules them all so in your early
turns you get about one mana per cycle
this one takes you from basically t1 to
t4 yeah yeah
t1 yeah okay tic-tac-toe right you get
the middle square times a billion that's
what it is bottom line if a skilled
player plays the Lotus game over so
you're saying it's pretty much like
worthless if you get it too late see
that is the problem with you people you
don't want to understand the game you
want to pay for a fancy fix someone
tried to teach it to me I just couldn't
get it so you don't want to play them
why do you need that what's left
all right what about Mellie mellows
let's go to Mellie mellows not going to
melly-mel hos well it'll just be the two
of us you love the coffee cake you know
we can't just leave your father here
good morning coffees cool plus I can't
eat the coffee cake what did that ever
the crumb topping gives me gas mom gas
and crumbs adults talk about gas and
crumbs Michael oh we can just scrape the
crumb topping off it's not worth eating
without the crumb topping traffic is
terrible are you on your way out
mm-hmm
[Music]
Michael how's the food it's great mom
we're the potatoes oh right I'll be
right back how's work Michael good good
how's business business is good so
Michael do you know if researchers
restrict the diet of mice by 50% it
extends their lifespan 35 to 65 percent
you know that starving mice live a half
lifetime longer than their fat ass
friends okay what they're starving all
of the sign sure
speaking of starving I don't want them
you know I don't like your potatoes I
love something mom all right you'll eat
anything it's good to have you home
again I think it's time to get rid of
all this stuff oh no no no your father
would never allow it he said I could do
whatever I want with my room oh he's not
gonna let you get rid of a perfectly
good guess who's gonna use it well your
kids maybe and you have them this is a
good desk
they don't make particle board this
solid anymore they used to a lot more
particles back then
that's good the kids won't have a VCR
there's a very large penis scene on it
mom you don't have to do this anymore
okay I'll take it put it with the other
tapes in the living room
no no all of this you have to live with
dad anymore I'm not leaving your father
Michael why not he's gotten so much
worse he barely lives the house and he's
filled it with so much crap you can't
even live in it divorce isn't what we do
what who does you hasn't been married
for 40 years Americans get divorced it
is what we do we didn't go into this
marriage expecting love we expected to
have a family well you did it
I'm grown-up I don't need you guys you
guys don't have to stay together for me
anymore you can't survive without me
it's my responsibility hire someone
there are services for old people you
guys don't have to live together oh I'm
happy I'm useful email usefulness isn't
centered around serving men anymore
well you would understand better if you
had a chance that love someone honey
[Music]
[Music]
hello sir welcome to cafe blah which
will happen type of reservation yeah it
should be under more Escobar